i don't know how much you know about
bringing computer interfaces in your
link the
the idea there is you know our brains
are very limited
and if we just allow we plug in
we provide a mechanism for a computer to
speak with the brain so you're thereby
expanding the computational power of the
brain
the possibilities there sort of from a
very high level philosophical
perspective is limitless but i wonder
how limitless it is are the constraints
we have like features that are
fundamental to our intelligence
or is this just like this weird
constraint in terms of our brain size
and skull
and uh lifespan and
senses it's just the weird little like
quirk of evolution
and if we just open that up like add
much more senses
add much more computational power the
intelligence will be will expand
exponentially
do you have a do you have a sense about
constraints the relationship of
evolutionary computation to the
constraints of the
[Music]
um well at first i'd like to comment on
on that
like changing the inputs uh to human
brain uh yes and
flexibility of the brain i think there's
a lot
of that there are experiments that are
done in animals like megan kasir
mit switching the um auditory and visual
information and going going to the wrong
part of the cortex and the animal
uh was still able to hear and perceive
the visual environment
and there are kids that are born with
severe disorders and sometimes they have
to remove
half of the brain like one half and they
still grow up they have the functions
migrate to the other parts
there's a lot of flexibility like that
so i think it's quite possible to
um hook up the brain with different
kinds of sensors for instance
and uh something that we don't even
quite understand or have today
on different kind of wavelengths or or
whatever they are
and then the brain can learn to make
sense of it and that
i think is um this good hope that these
prosthetic devices for instance work
not because we make them so good and so
easy to use but the brain adapts to them
and can learn to take advantage of them
um
and so in that sense if there's a
trouble a problem
i think that brain can be used to
correct it now going beyond what we have
today can you get smarter
that's really much harder to do giving
the brain more more input probably might
overwhelm it would
have to learn to filter it and focus um
in order to use the information
effectively
and augmenting intelligence
with some kind of external devices like
that might be difficult
uh i think but uh replacing what's lost
i think is quite possible
right so our intuition allows us to
sort of imagine that we can replace
what's been lost but
expansion beyond what we have i mean
we're already one of the most if not the
most intelligent things on this earth
right so
it's hard to imagine
um if the brain can hold up with an
order of magnitude greater set of
information
thrown at it if it can do if you can
reason through that
part of me this is the russian thing i
think is uh i tend to think that the
limitations is where the
superpower is that you know
immortality and a
huge increase in bandwidth of
information by connecting computers with
the brain is not going to produce
greater intelligence
it might produce lesser intelligence so
i don't know there's something about
the scarcity being essential
to uh fitness or performance
but that could be just because we're so
uh
limited no exactly you make two with
what you have but you can
uh you don't have to pipe it directly to
the brain i mean we already have
devices like phones where we can look up
information at any point
yeah and that can make us more
productive you don't have to argue about
i don't know what happened in that
baseball game or whatever it is
because you can look it up right away
and i think in that sense
we can learn to utilize tools and that's
what we
we have been doing for a long long time
um
so and we are already the brain is
already drinking from the water
fire hose like vision there's way more
information in the vision that we
actually process
so brain is already good at identifying
what matters
yeah and that we can switch that from
vision to some other wavelength or some
other kind of modality but i think that
the same
processing principles probably still
apply uh but but also
indeed this uh ability to uh
have information more accessible and
more relevant i think
can enhance what we do i mean kids today
at school
they learn about dna i mean things that
we discovered just a couple of years ago
uh and it's already common knowledge and
we are building on it and we don't see
a problem where um where
there's too much information that we can
absorb and learn maybe people become a
little bit more
narrow in what they know they are in one
field
uh but this information that we have
accumulated it is passed on and people
are picking up on it
and they are building on it so it's not
like we have reached the point of
saturation
um we have still this process that
allows us to be selective
and decide what's interesting um i think
still works
even even with the more information we
have today yeah it's fascinating to
think about
like wikipedia becoming a sensor like uh
so the fire hose of information from
wikipedia so it's like you
integrate it directly into the brain to
where you're thinking like you're
observing the world with all of
wikipedia directly piping into your
brain
so like uh when i see a light i
immediately have like the history of
who invented electricity like integrated
very quickly into so just the way you
think about the world might be very
interesting
if you can integrate that kind of
information what are your thoughts if i
could ask
uh on uh early steps on that on the
neuralink side i don't know if you got a
chance to see but uh
there was a monkey playing pong yeah
through the brain computer interface and
uh the dream there is sort of you're
already replacing the thumbs essentially
that you would use to play video game
the dream is to be able to
increase further the uh
the interface by which you interact with
the computer are you impressed by this
are you worried about this what are your
thoughts as a human
i think it's wonderful i think it's
great that we could we could do
something like that i mean you can
there are devices that read your eeg for
instance
and and you and humans can learn um
to control things using using just their
thoughts in that sense and
i i don't think it's that different i
mean those signals would go to limbs
they would go to thumbs
uh now the same signals go through a
sensor to
some computing system it still probably
has to be built
on human terms uh not to overwhelm them
but but utilize what's there and sense
the right kind of
um patterns that are easy to generate
but
oh that i think is really quite possible
and and wonderful and could be very much
more efficient
you